so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
topazio whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast i am here with my co-host marty
o'neal what's up folks what up what up
let's get let's get straight into this
let's get right into this today guys man
let's go you guys come on i understand
messaging me thousands of times hey ten
thousand thousands
[ __ ] it's the dj ghost episode all
right yeah welcome
what's up bro appreciate it appreciate
it mad early too man earlier
appreciate it i know i told you what was
this four months ago three months ago i
don't remember how long was i supposed
to do this yeah and [ __ ] kept coming up
you know i live all the way in vegas so
that's it
because it's better than you
you hit us up like yeah i'll be there
let's do it yeah more than just like yo
hurry up
that's why when i hit you on tuesday i'm
like but i'll be out there for sure yeah
and you're about to take off right right
out of texas right yeah i'm out of here
in two hours so i appreciate you being
here man yeah so marty i'm gonna start
this up a little bit early let's do it
start this up yeah yeah yeah no this is
a celebration of fire right oh gee
that's it nothing else oh perfect yeah
no no no i'm always smoking bro that's
it i didn't know
you only smoke papers only smoke og how
long i'm talking about papers you only
smoke papers you don't smoke no
backwoods no swishers no frontal leaves
no gravel is that on you oh man i need
me a grinder something you got anything
uh the homie got some if you got
something i got weed
yeah go ahead and roll that up for him
all right let me tell you what it is
what why are you why do you smoke papers
why do you smoke papers
i used to smoke blunts only swishers and
[ __ ] and like at like 22 i was smoking
so many packs i switched up the papers
one day and went
oh yeah breathe a little better man and
i think that's what got me with the weed
bro i think it just like that [ __ ] be
seeming too fresh when it's up in the
papers you know what i'm saying really i
love it it's pure you could taste it oh
it's but the hair changed i'm gonna keep
it 100 with you i think i'm addicted to
the tobacco that's in the lips that's
what it is you know what i'm saying i
have homies that only got backwards yeah
bro i think i'm addicted to the tobacco
scenario
a little bit of tobacco in your joint oh
yeah that's the hell no oh no you so
long so what they do like in england
like what they do is they roll halfway
new york needs to be talking about
spliff too yeah half weed half tobacco
it's because in new york and uh that's
what that stretch weed it's hard to say
hey hey you know what they said he said
they do what you you break down
they do half tobacco on your weed
and half you know half wheat half
tobacco on your joint as they do in
england it's hard to get weed or they
put hash in it
it's hard to get wheat out there that's
the hash on tobacco
that's like the same a little addiction
man it's like the same like that's still
a thing today i know hella fools that
only smokes bliss damn i won't smoke it
i won't smoke this no i ain't gonna
smoke well it's like i'm smoking if i'm
smoking it direct
huh yeah pretty much if for sure you got
a lighter and an asteroid right next to
you too all right y'all dope up in here
bro you're ready we're ready i'm gonna
sit up on the screen over there and
suppose it it's ready
that's done all right real quick what's
up first time i ever heard about you
let's drop this real quick was two three
no three years ago i think and i saw i'm
like yo this will just
react and the video was getting hot all
right and i didn't i didn't know when i
watch youtube i watch fights
and i get off i don't watch anything
else
you know i smoke a weed in the
background at work my dad got knocked
out and then they get straight off that
[ __ ] that's it so i didn't know reaction
videos were so popular i didn't realize
that i didn't know that it was popular
too i don't like
when i started i started off doing [ __ ]
like hip hop news you know what i'm
saying and that just with the picture
and my voice over
that's it yeah and so the fans like they
was [ __ ] with me i only had like nine
thousand subscribers like bro should do
reactions like yo shit's like funny you
just you know i'm saying you be keeping
it real
and so when i did that i'm just like
damn it blew up
and when i seen reactions bro it's like
all these reacting [ __ ] out here as
soon as they react to a song everybody
like every song they react to
even if it's garbage they'd be like all
this [ __ ] is dope
you know what i'm saying so when i got
on there i'm like
this [ __ ] why be in the mirror like
this [ __ ] garbage
no that's my boy that's an example i
never said that about him well i said
that about almighty j though that [ __ ]
[ __ ] garbage
but uh see your honest reviews man yeah
yeah yeah and a few other rappers i said
it straight up and they're like bro
you're the first thing that i kept on
100 then
they started rocking with it from there
and when i seen that they was [ __ ]
with me
and
not just the content i was doing
that's why i made a vlog channel you
know what i'm saying
then i made a podcast channel
then i made another reaction channel
where i reacted [ __ ] nothing but music
then i made a gaming channel
then i made another channel called og
ghost you know what i'm saying
all of it just blew up bro i just hit a
million subscribers for the second time
on my second channel that's crazy to me
you think about it like how in the 90s
like funk master flex dj clue all of
them were like the gatekeepers the
hip-hop their opinions mattered the fans
to them for their opinions do you feel
kind of like that in this new genre oh
yeah for sure cause
nowadays bo [ __ ] like me i'm in my 30s
now i respect them
they older they old school but the young
[ __ ] right now don't give a [ __ ] about
them
they [ __ ] with me right now you know
what i'm saying
so when i speak they listen that's why
i'm be trying to do no [ __ ] no clout
chase and [ __ ] or nothing like that
because
that [ __ ] be for real and they follow
your moves like everything you do
and y'all worry me power when you get
clout
like to keep in 100 once you start
getting
instagram followers and
millions of views and all these
subscribers about
people look at that clout and thank you
somebody or feel like you're somebody
and really want to [ __ ] with you all for
that and it's a lot of people they get
it don't know what to do with it that's
why they're not here no more it's true
you know what i'm saying and it's a lot
of people that
know how to like balance the [ __ ] and
they still around
look at snoop
this [ __ ] doing
cooking [ __ ] he doing
he on gucci ads he doing you know what
i'm saying once they mess with you bro
you you threw the rose yeah you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's why they dropped me some
merch
my merch doing you know i stopped
ordering merch too right now because say
stop ordering yeah stop ordering my
could i be getting too many orders
we were about to pick the store
i better say that bro i'm telling y'all
and they gonna try to be funny and order
after they see this [ __ ] y'all ain't
gonna get nothing until like the middle
of august
school by the start back it's still like
my kids you know
[ __ ] yeah don't order no merch right now
bro it's only me and my baby mommy
that's doing that [ __ ] right now and
it'd be too it's just way too much yeah
i'm saying i feel i just stopped for
this
i did all my orders every package out
the house ever got to print the label
address people dm you my order there yet
like you just emailed me you just you
just meant to order 10 minutes how the
[ __ ] is going to get to chicago in 10
minutes you know what i'm saying i
ordered overnight shipping i don't offer
overnight shipping right talking about
it but i don't even send to the uk it
takes forever not only that it just
costs money
if it's not in the us bro that ghost
game emerges
that's too bad
[ __ ] it's too bad i'm not saying that i
don't think i ever heard anybody ask
please stop i can't keep up
love that [ __ ] that's real though
because yeah i can't try to just take as
much money as they can get off the fans
yeah i'm sure yeah i can't do it right
now i love that
in the middle and a half middle of
august yeah we'll get back up never
thought of uh
someone handling fulfillment for you
yeah ain't no you know what i'm saying i
don't really
it's hard to trust [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying you know what's gonna do
better than you yeah yeah like i don't
have been there that's why jobs and [ __ ]
don't really work i got fired because my
manager didn't like me what'd you work
at i worked at walmart
oh [ __ ] i was stocking boxes at walmart
like early in the morning when the truck
comes and [ __ ]
you gotta know what videos i was there
for now i wasn't doing videos i was in
my 20s and i was there for a few months
but we got a new manager that [ __ ]
didn't like me i was out of there like
three weeks you know what i'm saying
and so yeah i don't really [ __ ] with
[ __ ] that's why
the thing about a job bro you can have
you an apartment you can have your house
your kids your girl your wife cardinals
and all that type of [ __ ]
if your manager don't like you he can
end online
it's it's it's on my kids
yeah yeah yeah so you got to act like
you like somebody just so you can keep
your life straight your girl happy your
kids fed and all that type of [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
and i say that because when i got fired
um
after that i was homeless i was in
bakersfield at the time you know i'm
saying
so all right yeah
and i was homeless bro and i was living
in my car that's why i said when you two
came from lacking officers i don't have
nothing else to do i was a felon i went
to jail when i was 23 so that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up
and so me making youtube videos on my
core i think that's when people
connected you know i'm saying because
they ain't seen nobody living in their
car making youtube videos
and you know it just
it just went from there it was just down
far but i lost my kids i lost my
apartment i lost everything [ __ ] after
you got fired yeah so my mama got sick
my mom got sick i moved to vegas it's
like 2017.
and uh
yeah that's when i just went hard this
[ __ ]
and that's when i started that little
relationship with the video i was
telling yeah that's why today bo this is
my first ever interview i've ever did in
my life
because
i just
don't trust people if you go to my
youtube channels i got four thousand
videos without one collab you know what
i'm saying
and the reason and every four thousand
videos not one collab
i want a [ __ ] telling me putting me on
cause i'm gonna want to fight
i don't want a [ __ ] telling me he did
this for me i've been through all that
before
and with the youtube [ __ ]
it's either if you work you make it if
you don't you don't i'm gonna bet on
myself but i don't work hard as [ __ ]
that [ __ ] and that's why i just yeah you
were doing music before youtube i was
doing music from
when i was 18 to like
29 years old that [ __ ] didn't go nowhere
bro but did you get a lot of distrust of
people through that yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was [ __ ] with like little local
labels and all that but
you know people don't want to [ __ ] with
you until they see you
actually making moves or see somebody
else that got some kind of statue 100
yeah i hate that feeling and i when i
noticed it it was only my friend and
[ __ ] on me watching it i'm doing this
[ __ ] for 11 years at this point
like i got to do something else but i
love it i got to do something else
and that's why when i started the
youtube
when people [ __ ] with you like i said
they [ __ ] with you so now when i drive
my music videos i'm getting a million
views in two days every time i drop 500
000 views million views
i got
the dopest beats from hit boy right now
that [ __ ] sending me some beats i got
the doubles collabs from all these rap
[ __ ] and it's because the way i move
bro i don't
want none from nobody
and if the relationship genuine i'm
[ __ ] with it 100 i'm [ __ ] with it
that's why i hit you i mean when you hit
me up to do this [ __ ] i'm like
bro cool i looked at your page you don't
seem like no clout chasing ass [ __ ] you
don't you know what i'm saying like i'm
gonna go [ __ ] with y'all yeah that's why
i think it comes from uh you weren't
trying to be a youtuber it's like yo let
me try this [ __ ] same way i was just
selling packs and a lot of [ __ ] try
youtube because they like videos and
content they love this [ __ ] i like to be
real i tried it i did it for the money
bro i didn't fall in love with youtube
to like
probably six eight months after i
started doing it i was just chasing the
bag i wanted to get money i wanted to
get money well that's my first you're in
the car like i need to do something
different
bro first first month twenty seven
dollar check first second one sixty
three dollar check you remember that
[ __ ] starting youtube
what you mean i don't get paid on my
channel why not because i show weed
i've never been paid on my channel his
main channel he's got a weed channel
over a million he's got like he's got
three channels including this 2.1 mill
they owe me and you won't get no actions
my [ __ ] is transparent bar
it sells money and it doesn't give me
the money
yeah and two years ago they said [ __ ]
you you're never gonna be monetized
again they did that on my boy mr thc
that's [ __ ] up they didn't get paid at
all
so what you doing i mean ads and
sponsors and [ __ ] like that
i have a uh the clothing company yeah i
have another cup i have like six
companies that run so why you won't make
you another channel where you don't show
the weed i do that's what's up i do i
have oh that's what this one is well i
have another channel called the
adventures where i do vlogs family
friendly [ __ ] oh okay but it's not as
fun it's not as fun
i'd rather be like [ __ ] i'm struggling a
little bit i couldn't get it over here
so this one right here you're getting
paid for huh we do get paid we can [ __ ]
with heavies
hey look let me tell you just don't
cuss within the first 30 seconds bro
don't like nut don't do nothing within
the first 30 seconds you'll be over 10
minute nice guy clock is what we have on
this channel yeah we started it early
cause i'm like i want to smoke
they won't really you know i'm saying
they understandable youtube not no
busters like that and then you got to be
up in the uh up in the city where the
weirdest league was too yeah i've been
here though every time yeah man i never
got paid your ips address you let them
know where you're at in this game
though spotify is going out of their way
to show us love
we're partnering with spotify yeah
spotify yeah i don't even know you ain't
no spotify you hear my little uh drops
of me on the commercial hey what's up
man come watch our show oh that's hard
so this one will hype it up with them
they'll run a little ad campaign like
you'll watch the dj ghost episode on the
dopes usually
it's just weird to hear it like this
[ __ ] sounds professional yeah [ __ ]
that's cool
so once you got your [ __ ] on spotify you
got to deal with them
oh we got to deal with no like we're
talking we're like talking
yeah of course
yeah yeah we're moving i got one but i
do that [ __ ] once every four months or
something like that a week man do it
once a week cause people like you they
just want it even if you just do this
here's my favorite movies in order oh
they're going to listen to you
they want to talk to you they just want
to
remember remember that time when you're
by yourself you're smoking a joint but i
got nobody here with me
and you connect with the person they say
one thing now you're homies so remember
a lot of people don't have that so you
are that that's why you gotta fall in
dude people fight how many of you how
many how many times you go up a week
with your pocket once a week every
monday yeah yeah every monday that's
dope so do you chop these up or you put
them all out at one time marty does all
the edits all everything you chop him up
marty how many videos you gonna get
so we got the full-length episode on
like five clips and a couple verticals
okay
okay
so you got to do the clips bro that's
where it's going to yeah yeah you got to
do the clips then we're driving on his
dobaziola channel once a week two and a
half years [ __ ] oh we should do one
starter twitch twitch podcast or twitch
gaming no i just smoke weed on this game
over here i'm about to i just started
last week dude what you playing [ __ ]
with me
yo look people [ __ ]
[ __ ] my dms my youtube comments it's
crazy huh go to yola i'm telling you
you're like go to yoga because you two
are gonna go down in the history books
of youtube people are making it by their
stories just like just talking to being
yourself you had never gone hold on hold
on let me get ready hey what's up
youtube i know you don't do that [ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ] up
man all right subscribe to my channel
other than that like it's not gonna be
that way man y'all got that backwood
i want to hit that
that's not a bad word what's that uh
aj
yeah when last time you smoke smoke some
tobacco the last time i smoked the back
was when i did how to roll a blunt video
because everybody kept asking like i
know how to roll blunts just don't
really smoke them because i used to
smoke nothing but blunts when i was
selling packs and [ __ ] until i was like
21. and i switched over to the joints
like i said they got me doing reactions
they got me doing all that [ __ ] but
certain [ __ ] i don't do that they always
ask me to show you how to roll the blunt
it's cause bro when i upload my videos
you know you got that well you know you
got the 18 or you gotta push 18.
don't worry
you got kids watching bro and i don't
want them to be like dj go show me how
to roll the whoopee whoop whoop like
[ __ ]
it's a fair point you know what i'm
saying
you're on the good side of youtube man
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because he just every time i mean he's
blowing right at the camera the whole
time but he's not sitting there doing
macro reviews yeah i'm over here that's
not even weird that's that's tobacco
that ain't we don't listen to the hype
there you go there you go bro i just
make it look like it's weird to be cool
i want to be cool like everybody else
i'm a rapper yeah be cool
so uh how many pages you got total
five damn i just got my tenth plaque
till my 10 of you to apply
no [ __ ] yeah like a hundred thousand and
then yeah i got i got i got
two million plaques and eight hundred
thousand uh
eight hundred thousand plus quick two
right like in the past like two years
basically right like since three and a
half yeah three three and a half years
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
now they rocking with me right now man
that's why i love it man i love it stay
up to date stay on topics but i know my
kids birthdays my mama bro my mom passed
a couple months ago bro i'm still
getting a
you know what i'm saying the grief and
all that like the subscribers they
change our lives yours yourself i wanna
say the same thing yeah bro that [ __ ]
crazy i said crazy like overwhelming to
a point you know what i'm saying
like [ __ ] love you they don't even
know you
[ __ ] happens in life and it's like you
know you're gonna have to go over it
like your life is
you have no choice but to go over it
with the fans yeah yeah yeah i got on
camera when it happened you know i cried
on camera it's emotional i'm not
deleting none of that yeah everybody go
through it you know what i'm saying yeah
and they just help somebody man yeah
that [ __ ] that's all
to the fans like right
and just be cool and be pure to them
like i said they put you in this
position you just gotta don't squander
that yeah keep it 100 with him if you
keep it 100 with him you straight [ __ ]
you see him don't be on that michael
jordan [ __ ] and not take a picture
with him thank you what the [ __ ] are you
you seeing that [ __ ]
and a little [ __ ] had some shoes on
yeah
you know what's crazy though i was
thinking about when you're telling your
story had you not been in that position
in your car though would you not be here
today like this struggling rapper
trying to make it yeah that's the only
thing i would have had like i said
the world looked at you [ __ ] up when
you were feeling
no job no apartment
that [ __ ] just it tanks you for
however long i should stay on your
record what is it seven years or
something like seven yeah so what you
gonna do
what you gonna do bro chill out the
house while your baby wanna work
sell something
rapping is the only legal way
you know what i'm saying it's the only
legal way you can't go to sports because
if you ain't doing that [ __ ] while
you're in high school you got a chance
you ain't coming off the street to the
nba i should only in movies you know
what i'm saying
you ain't coming off the street to the
nfl to the major leagues and that's
so it's
struggling rapper
i made a vow to myself when i was 27 i'm
done with anything illegal anybody that
[ __ ] with it
i promise you both
like they got love [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying that do they thing but as far
as kicking in with them every day having
them in my circle
that [ __ ] not there with me don't worry
bro i don't [ __ ] around
i feel you so i'm just actually don't
[ __ ] around reserve finally
just like overall just like i'm at a
different this might sound cliche
but when i had my kids bro my first kid
was born with autism you know i'm saying
he disabled
and
if i'm out there leaving that on my baby
mama that [ __ ] would have [ __ ] me up
then i had another one who want to be
just like me you know what i'm saying
it just i was just cool bro i was just
straight on everything
i just been through a lot of [ __ ] yeah
been through a lot of [ __ ]
the youtube [ __ ] why do something
illegal once i got here it's just like i
was just telling them like i'm gonna
move to the forest in oregon after i
leave out of there that [ __ ] like i'm
feeling i'm gonna die out there i
usually
it's all about who you know just like
you can go to [ __ ] anywhere it's all
about who you know
organ is the [ __ ] there's no sales tax
the housing is low there's no sales tax
you go to the store oh it's just how
much is shirt
99 it's 99 cents done that's why you go
up there and buy designer [ __ ] and leave
because where's that tax coming
from
it's [ __ ] sick so right now how the
weed is out there it's cool it's cool
because there's indoor okay outdoors now
i'm talking about the laws is legal
fully bro for real fully you're fine
you should look this up but last year
they were talking about making coke and
heroin legal out there too
i'm not even kidding because they're
like yo we're arresting people for what
they're adults the thing about that is
it's like every other law once they hit
one one one state it's gonna hit all the
other ones yeah
country full of crackheads bro
they're just talking about like not
arresting him put him in prison for
possession for re like having a strike
and possession yeah ignore you're a drug
addict get help first i i kind of [ __ ]
with that because i know a lot of drug
addicts so
i get it that [ __ ] probably cap you
still got [ __ ] doing time for weed
that got arrested 10 years ago bro
they're still in prison right now still
got five years left still got seven
years left over two pounds a week type
[ __ ] yeah mommy's facing uh
six years in in texas right now over
some some waves or some packs
if you get if you get pulled over with
that [ __ ]
today it's
this is today but it's in texas oh yeah
i thought you just told my life
yeah they don't [ __ ] they still ride
around the horses and sombreros and [ __ ]
out there bro they ain't [ __ ] around
out there anything bro they don't [ __ ]
with you at all out there if you i don't
know what it is texas is the only state
in the um united states right now i
still got the death penalty
no [ __ ] yeah look that [ __ ] up
legal injections i'm pretty sure i'm
pretty sure they're the only state right
now and i got the death penalty i tried
to give you that [ __ ] over some weed too
anytime i was in texas i felt
uncomfortable like i didn't even have we
just knowing
people that are supposed to protect you
are willing to just do this to you over
this [ __ ] marty's from new york from
buffalo yeah he hated it off the top
yeah so he [ __ ] that weed up there
right [ __ ] let's not talk about the weed
in buffalo at least back in the [ __ ]
i don't think no weed on the east coast
it's good bro
it's from here
no they say it's from here that's how
they get you everybody say everybody say
they got that cali yeah everybody loves
it they got that cali bro so what do you
got out of town they said i got that
county i should be garbage i bring my
weight out out of stuff i bet you a lot
of st
well how you doing oh never mind just
telling me off for this [ __ ]
you ready
ready yeah i call whatever [ __ ]
airline i'm going to and tell them my
flight go y'all have this amount of weed
on me don't touch my [ __ ] here's my card
here's my [ __ ] i'm a patient i'm going
to another state that's wrecked and i
put my wreck on it i duct tape my jars
in case folks want to take nugs out of
my [ __ ] yeah put my
put my uh id photo on top of my weed and
i put a note don't touch my politely
like you don't touch me bro so you know
videos on this bro are you flying to
other states where the weed is legal i
flew over and had a stop in utah and i
said hey i'm making a stop in utah am i
gonna get arrested when i stop in utah
they go you shouldn't that's not a
reassuring [ __ ] no i don't know
check this out yeah i have it on tape on
snapchat and everything yeah check this
out bro
called tsa i thought i was gonna go to
jail if i take i just went to hawaii
right probably like
three weeks ago
i didn't take nothing because i thought
i was gonna go to jail and i'm out there
bro
they we [ __ ] up my vacation that's
just
hey [ __ ] hawaii bro they weeded so
garbage out there that [ __ ] oh you think
you'd be the opposite and they got and
they got islands out there you know what
i'm saying
so as soon as i touch down you already
know i'm in a story like hey i'm right
here these wait so everybody like all
from this island i'm 30 minutes away i'm
an hour away another [ __ ] i'm 10
minutes away another [ __ ] i'm right
here i'm like five minutes
they all pull up on me bro with the same
weed
no that [ __ ] was so it's like they grow
their weed in the sand out there bro
i ain't never tasting no weed so i will
never go back to hobart in my life and i
would never
recognize don't be like oh ghost you
just had a bad experience no the [ __ ] i
didn't i mean yeah i did but you will
too bro don't go to hawaii
you did a crosstalk garbage bro i'm
telling you
don't go to hawaii
don't do it my mom liver lived there for
four years and never visited her once
yeah don't feel like that [ __ ] i just
hate the water why she only stayed for
four years
she got divorced [ __ ]
she moved back home it wasn't her duel
hawaii made her get divorced but i'm
telling you was the weed yeah it was a
weird and she don't even smoke it's
still a weed that maybe you get more at
that time either [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] is
garbage no my homie did tell me that the
weed's kind of bad out there but there's
some kind of stretching it though that
[ __ ]
like that bad like long nuggets you
smoke a stretch weed back in the day of
course yeah
i was a little kid like all right so
it's like you smoking a z back in the
day that arizona weed [ __ ] was great it
wasn't brown
all right it's like
in between az and stress right there
yeah that stay chronic
that's the chronic out there they don't
yeah that [ __ ] they brought to dj ghosts
when they broke
one nugget
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] it just
went legal there though so it's probably
like early no they got shops out there
the same [ __ ] really yeah it probably is
bro i'm sorry i know they get it from
the same plug for sure it was the same
exact way i'll buy it i'm gonna drop
that vlog i'm gonna drop that vlogging
light and probably like four days you'll
see [ __ ] i was out there tripping damn
yeah
all they got is swishers
yeah
killing me bro
hawaiian pineapples and [ __ ] though
hawaii was a bad experience do you do
you edit all your own vlogs and stuff
yeah i do everything i don't [ __ ] with
nobody everything i don't know [ __ ] with
nobody
i mean not like that though but no i
know what you mean like i want to do my
own [ __ ] it's just like if you're doing
a vlog say do a vlog right
and you you know i'll be vlogging in the
house i vlog everywhere
and um
it's me i'm talking then i walk past my
kids my girl whatever the case
they laughing she might see something or
say something
and then i go to the vlogs and i edit it
up
okay nobody edit your vlogs like you do
you know what i'm saying
if i say [ __ ] you get out the way
he might not know i'm playing with my
girl my vlog so he might put it in there
or do i take it out of there type [ __ ]
like nobody can do it how you you
understand i stopped editing when i met
marty oh i stopped
final editing i used to edit everything
until like 20 20. so i do the rough cut
all what i want to say and then i have
to do the cool [ __ ] and now i kind of
handed that off because i'm like yo if i
say some stupid ass [ __ ] don't put it in
i'll be keeping that in there though i
keep everything in there i feel like
everybody like me bro everybody just a
regular [ __ ] that'd be [ __ ] up like
[ __ ] where i did that whole tupac
reaction with a booger in my nose man
i was mad as [ __ ]
i would drop that [ __ ] next when you
took me like
i came out here about to drop that [ __ ]
i was looking at the video i'm like [ __ ]
it it was 42 minutes long
[Laughter]
i'm like man i'm gonna be here for 42
minutes clown and i finished scratch
this video all right did you edit this
[ __ ]
huh did you edit the video at all [ __ ]
it's in my nose i know but i'm saying
when you're editing you're like staring
at like [ __ ] oh yes bro
to me it's covering the whole screen
yeah but it's really just right here
what i'm looking at is covering the
whole screen
i did the new york vlog as i'm looking
at it it wasn't even it was it was
hanging too from my nose to my mustache
i'm like damn bro it was like five
o'clock in the morning
so how many videos how long does it take
you to bust this out and edit this [ __ ]
i'm assuming a couple hours right what
film and edit a video done a vlog or a
reaction reaction video quick right
a reaction yeah that reaction video
it all depends how long it takes me to
record it i mean sometimes the video
could be two minutes
and i react to that [ __ ] for 50 minutes
on a video you know what i'm saying but
um as far as editing editing only take
like four minutes
four yeah three minutes maybe only
reaction it's the vlogs that'll take me
like
30 minutes 40 minutes you know what i'm
saying because i like to watch and look
through every clip
i don't just take the cool [ __ ] out then
i don't like to edit them i like that
if i fall on the vlog
i put that my mama fell in the pool
that's still in the vlog oh my mama fell
off a bike that's still in the vlog like
i feel everybody is normal bro yes and i
think that's why people connect yeah
like everybody normal the only [ __ ] i
cut is when i'm like that
[ __ ] up [ __ ] words
on my other channel my vlog channel i'm
high as [ __ ] but i don't show it it's
not youtube my family friendly man and
so i'm i [ __ ] my words up 20 times i'll
actually
have to read you my line i'm like
naughty [ __ ] saying that yeah that [ __ ]
is cool on youtube because we're just
cool on youtube you cussing your family
friendly channel i'm smoking all my [ __ ]
oh yeah
oh no
hell yeah i'll be big doing that don't
kill me
that's probably because you're not
putting are you putting in that 18 and
older
no
yeah that's why you're getting messed up
you put when you edit your vlog i mean
when you go to when you upload your
video right there where you title it go
all the way down they go say is this
vlog made for kids or anything you know
made for not made for kids cause that
like chops the fuse in half literally
for us if we were to age restricted off
top like no that's that don't hurt you
straight your videos
making it 18 and over do not edge
restrict your videos oh because i get
all my videos in the back end and
sometimes they're blocked yeah when you
get your videos as you restricted bro
all right well yeah we'll talk off
camera okay okay thank you thank you
thank you god you got something man yeah
yeah yeah
they deleted my youtube man and then he
got it back for me [ __ ] a month later
the night before we had another 400
million
995
deleted what
what
you tell me man no strikes either not
one stray deleted the whole page it was
probably an accident you know youtube
got um that's nearly deleted a few
people's videos you know my whole
channel so where they i mean channels
it's a group of creators they got videos
where they went to the youtube office
because they uh challenge got deleted
they hold challenges bro it's
almost came to that yeah
you know they're right up there i think
i like san francisco or something i went
to prison
yeah they up there they delete me on
instagram every month basically so i
went to ig one time
get the [ __ ] out of here that's what
they told me sign this feel this and get
the [ __ ] out oh they were straight yeah
they weren't helping me they don't give
a [ __ ] about me yeah i'm on my 27th
account on instagram bro i get deleted
like every month oh yeah what is it
because of the trade joy i don't even
show weed no more
oh i said you stopped selling you still
got it
still get deleted
i still get to leave not showing no weed
that's crazy yeah i'm on this weird
blacklist [ __ ] right now i guess that's
crazy yeah it's weird man so when i see
you got billboards got forbes article
dressed up and all this like i think you
know checkmark
forbes article y'all to get money you
didn't see that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was crazy
you guys wanted to be selling packs at
the very beginning of this [ __ ] for real
yeah this is the most popular content
cannabis in the world what
oh that's your mind blowing bro it's my
blog me my my company the dopest all the
pens and all the edibles and [ __ ]
that's my company i have my homies and
we did like an article because we're
we're like number two in the country
right now but we don't do wholesale or
nothing so we're crushing these fools oh
that is hard yeah i'm [ __ ] stoked
bro thank you thank you thank you that's
hard yeah but i still get deleted that's
he's like yo you do all this [ __ ] and
still get [ __ ] with
it's probably just probably some
automatic i don't think nobody just
pressing the button on you like that not
that youtube i don't think youtube likes
no not even youtube it's everywhere oh
and snapchat got deleted too what number
two in america
got deleted yeah it's a fact yeah yeah
we're working on it though we just
signed a deal that word yeah we just
signed up is it the dope in your name i
changed my name it's been yola youtube
for [ __ ] five years three years
i still get that [ __ ] deleted
i've been paying fools on instagram loki
and to get it back
and they get it back and it gets deleted
again i just lost how many thousands of
dollars like
it's a bummer they try to charge me 50
the other day 50 bands to get money i
got a patreon um i it was it took too
much to my time
honestly i tried you got an app
dopeyzola.com
notifications
let me tell you like this
y'all get mad oh well so what look
the patreon i had a patreon for a year
right so i uploaded probably like four
five videos a month on here
but these videos [ __ ] they be
beheadings it's emotional [ __ ] you can't
put on youtube
[ __ ] oh you're reacting to [ __ ] like
that yeah
so
i was probably getting like
2 000
um patrons a month
i'm like bro y'all ain't subscribing for
show
stop uploading i'm like the videos on
patreon i stopped by blowing to youtube
for like two weeks
after that i was getting like 20 000
patriots a month ago different people
yeah
that's insane
you crushed this [ __ ] though i got i got
to be honest i don't think i've ever
seen somebody do whatever they want
every category and still [ __ ] just
crush it that's oh yeah gaming channel
get the vlog got this got the product
[ __ ] yeah yeah
love it that's what how long have you
been having on like twitch and discord
with the role play and all that
that's a year
barely a year even a year yeah wow man
yeah my homies put me up on rp
shout out my boyfriend's gucci uh uh uh
nino sean they put me up on it you know
what i'm saying she's getting there
i don't know yeah yeah like gang banging
in real life man i do that on gta rp
yeah i get up in there get my guns out
drags out
with your homies and [ __ ] yeah
get paid to go it's called gritty world
rp on 5n yeah
yeah i got my own server oh that's
what's called the server that's yeah my
own server i'm so bad at this game we're
still learning about this we're we're
tapping into the game what you do bro
you come up in there and i said hell
yeah i got the pc all that [ __ ] behind
that curtain oh you tripping y'all have
to get up this week though i just got it
all set up you know i just got it it's
gonna try to take you like two hours to
download everything
yeah i got my homie i just got a new i'm
moving so i got an extra room so i can
turn it into like my twitch room and
[ __ ] okay it's like smoking cool [ __ ] i
don't know i don't want to have to come
to my warehouse every time i want to get
on twitch real quick it might be 12 at
night i want to smoke bowls and talk to
people and [ __ ] yeah i need to do it at
home you know yeah yeah damn dude you do
so much this is your full-time job this
is what you do yeah that's what i do bro
that's why i do it yeah i'm an internet
[ __ ] now you know saying i'm a youtuber
that's it
school is cool i [ __ ] with it and you i
we marty marty's been watching you for a
long last time appreciate it yeah i i
like i said it was like two two and a
half years ago when i first saw you all
right
you do story times too yeah i stopped
them why'd you stop them cause i'm gonna
be the first youtuber to get indicted
you know how they ain't that young thug
[ __ ]
my [ __ ] gets wild too i feel you yeah i
always go how many years i'm good
that's why you're so high you start
cutting the statue of limitations dude
i'm like you know what no no no no and
then you're gonna he's dead actually i'm
good yeah i think that guy died i'm fine
it does it is crazy bro and i yeah i'm
cold i thought i just talked about
i don't i think it's the contrast of
[ __ ] though like you know
how many packs like yeah
packs it's just because you don't see i
used to sell pizza and [ __ ] yeah you
dropped packs off while i was selling
pizza during like college damn it was
crazy bro it's cause nobody pulls the
pizza guy over so i would leave that
sign on yeah after work but like i would
come in with my my bag yeah my scale on
my pant whatever
because it's my homie's house i just it
just looks like the pizza guy walked in
i had to chit down for four years right
i only did the pizza just so much more
money that you made at your job for sure
30 minutes flat every day my whole check
was less than what i made in 30 minutes
selling
you know what i'm saying like
tax i know culpable old dudes i tax on
zips for like 350. like i just made my
whole check um that's it he started
doing reenactments on story time yeah
and we just did a full reenactment of
him going out dealing with a seven foot
racist with the pizza box
while he was vlogging no so i do story
time right yeah and i'm like you know
what let's see oh you reenact those
storytelling i got my homie to like with
the like with the cinema [ __ ] y'all own
one right now i'm trying it because
we're trying to pitch your [ __ ] to
netflix man cause we got some fools
doing some stuff and i think you have
like an actual chance of making oh you
got plugs you got plugs we're trying we
got plugs we're hella trying right now i
told you i don't [ __ ] with [ __ ] i don't
know nobody at netflix hulu oh i don't
know anything else
no we're trying to make like a portfolio
but look look at this following we got
give us a [ __ ] show on a budget
what's wrong with you all right you know
because i would watch your slider yeah
appreciate it you don't want to say like
i would watch this [ __ ]
what if you had somebody acting you just
talked about your stories and like yo
this is my life
i would that would be that [ __ ] show
reenact story times you see what i'm
saying like i don't watch that show
they shouldn't be on that now he
shouldn't have said that they're gonna
be on this oh they can do whatever they
want they can't take me no i'm talking
about the fans they finna bug us on that
[ __ ] oh they already do it they don't
bother you they tag netflix off for me
all the time man
we got we have some [ __ ] we're trying
but like we said we move uh we signed a
deal we're moving uh studios
we're with another media company so it's
like tyson
matt barnes us like now we're like in
the same studio so we're going to move
our whole [ __ ] okay so we're going to be
like uh you tell them all that hot
boxing podcast mike tyson yeah he's got
his so like our set they're going to
recreate our set at like some wayne's
world [ __ ] okay when they walk in it's
not wayne's [ __ ] basement like
exactly
my ties
well then we're going to be best friends
they only smoke pipers yeah yeah
all this [ __ ] is laid out yeah when you
see this production man when you really
see production they shoot it like a tv
show yeah like a commercial that's dope
it's just us it's just us it's me and
him every day always being just y'all
too yeah it's just me and him mm-hmm so
who came up with the idea though i mean
both of us kind of
already did so you were just like let's
get on youtube and start something up no
marty does uh marty stopped all of it
but marty
who you working for like he does all the
big communities like the rogan [ __ ] theo
vaughn all the other stuff marty's like
the uh
would you call it media management yeah
so that's what he did and i was like
y'all want to start a podcast and this
will hit me up
like let's do this [ __ ] together so he
kind of takes on all the roles of all
those comedian shows and we're like i'm
gonna do my own thing so that's why we
kind of people need to start showing
youtube more respect bro because
everybody start like stumping ground
where they start out as youtube
everybody all the big podcasts are the
spotify deals they move on netflix and
all that type of [ __ ] all these ravaged
people i'm not a youtube rapper
if i was youtube i delete them [ __ ]
channels
bro you gonna try to dummy down i think
you just made millions on my [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying yeah i love youtube
[ __ ] i love you that [ __ ] changed my
life bro
you two for real time
packs moved into youtube started push
trees that paid for the warehouse i had
the podcast yeah i would have like two
[ __ ] kids living in merced selling
packs working like a [ __ ] the city or
something i know what i know doesn't
sound bad but i knew what i needed to do
different right
you know we got like you got a [ __ ]
cult following that's like i know you're
live yeah thank you for being there and
that's just i appreciate it like
yeah for real it's the craziest feeling
for real crazy [ __ ]
they praying i'm making home on my
flight and samoa
what's up guys i know i know you're
super stoked the first dj ghost episode
of all time real quick we're just gonna
take a moment to talk about one of our
sponsors and this is miller lite just in
case you're already drinking drink
responsibly drive responsibly don't
drink and drive so millerlite.com
forward slash you'll listen to a landing
page every place that'll deliver you
beer or like we said if you're not
already drinking just drive to the store
any store on earth and find miller lite
guys it's august what does that mean to
a lot of americans football's almost
back football sundays marty said this as
we started this episode there's nothing
better than a 10 o'clock beer watching
the bills that's literally what marty
said that football sunday guys you know
the environment you're putting your
chips in your stuff you're getting
everybody ready you're calling your
homies like you're gonna lose and once
you crack open that first beer that's it
it's over that is football sunday so you
might as well make it a miller like but
now for real every time you drink real
life you're supporting us man the more
the better we appreciate it so once
again go to millerlite.com forward slash
yolo that's going to take you to a
landing page every place that'll deliver
your beer if not go to the store and
grab yourself a 12 pack and always guys
please celebrate responsibly from the
miller brewing company in milwaukee
wisconsin for all the healthy people out
there 96 calories 3.2 grams of carbs per
can with that being said guys thank you
for supporting the brands that support
us back to the episode
yeah making videos bro yesterday i said
crazy to me
it's crazy to me we hate flying to begin
with i hate it i can't stand it i hate
it with a passion bro i just close bro
as soon as the turbulence comes it's
like my heart goes straight to my eyes
i'll be so like the worst roller coaster
in the world no matter how many times
you do it still every time it's the
worst it just ain't no safety valve like
this [ __ ] go down bro done one thing i
don't like is they don't give passengers
parachutes that's just stupid [ __ ] that
was our topic last week man for real i
was like i don't have a parachute on my
[ __ ] shoulder he'll get a passenger
parachute
put a parachute on the plane yeah and
then all the fans sent me a video of a
plane going to the parachute through the
parachute
on the back of her on the back of
certain planes now that's in dubai they
don't [ __ ] with us like this why don't
we just have our chair do this put that
strap on your chair yeah put forward as
a parachute and you get hard you can
eject that [ __ ] how the pilots do
someone's a plane going down you can
push that button with the i need a
chance just give me a chance yeah give
me a big ass
mustang jeff bezos y'all invested your
money in the wrong [ __ ]
then y'all need to put you up here for
real
bro if i know that my life is good for
real life for sure
you know what's crazy as scary as it is
they say it's more um safer than driving
a car i'd rather do this i almost died
yeah then hey that [ __ ] old man up
there is [ __ ] up driving fly this
[ __ ]
[Music]
and then they got the nerd to put a
[ __ ] seat belt on the plane like what
the [ __ ] is it gonna do hey
[Laughter]
so they gonna do nothing man they
probably make it worse
i know the plane going down i want to
move around [ __ ] trying to get out of
here you know what i'm saying
one of the story times he reenacted was
i almost died
crashing back forever bro
it was a scary [ __ ] in my life you go
bro nah we lifted it up out of our seats
our [ __ ] was going oh [ __ ] started
traveling
oh it was it was starting to hurt it was
bad it was in the winter
yeah hail storms it sounded like
[ __ ] [ __ ] that that [ __ ] was it was
not gonna miss that money that family
reunion i will miss i'll drive the
winner i don't fly in the winter bro i
didn't know i'm at the house in the
winter i don't fly in the winter bro
i've been on too many scary ass like to
where the things come out the cylinders
some more you got you seen that yeah
twice on everything i love them they
were both in the winter one time when i
went to florida i went to jacksonville
and another time i went to uh what kind
of sophomore with the saint louis
and that [ __ ] happened scariest [ __ ]
that's the that's way worse than what i
got never mind i lifted out my seat i
thought i was like i'm gonna die no you
saw that dinner then you knew you got
the uh
flight flight of tennis running today's
season [ __ ] that's when i lost my [ __ ]
yeah when you when they don't know what
to do that's what it was like the guy
looked like he was gonna cry he was a
scary old mean ass man and he started
running for his life and why they like
that bro i have some old-ass females too
why they be old movies they try to be
making it seem like flight intended to
be fun as [ __ ]
don't they
i see the cute fighter
in my life
flying like a [ __ ] all right
damn my line dude with a lot of
personality i probably see it
lady that's like 60 but other than no no
never seen no like i don't think i've
ever heard nothing more true in my life
you ain't never say that
and i feel bad if i was on your flight
recently i'm very excited yeah yeah i
don't
know
that's it joe
are you hold
hawaii though you had the little first
class pot or some [ __ ] right oh you seen
it yeah yeah i flew uh oh you not it
yeah that [ __ ] was dope i'll do a nice
day and they had a bit that [ __ ] laid
out to a bed bro
you had a bed you got your own
refrigerator your own tv damn i'd be too
tempted you have all that [ __ ] what
class is that because that's not just
first class that's first class bro it
was first class
there's different levels of first class
right no no see if you fly under two
hours
they get you the first class to where
it's just two seats with the extra leg
room
but if you're flying more than two hours
they give you the first class with all
the
the stake in the lobster [ __ ] the
hennessy the all that [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying forget about your flight yeah
and i was knocked out i was knocked out
bro i need man they just need to if you
could smoke on the plane bro that's what
i'm saying like i would give a [ __ ]
about that
i'd be tempted hold on you weren't
ripping the three hash pens at a time on
the plane i will not say that because i
need to take okay
so hold on so you stopped doing story
times because you didn't want to get
into this no i'm not i was just a joke i
stopped doing it i stopped doing story
times like
just because three years ago bro just
because yeah last one i did was like
three years ago but they want to bring
them back like hell no that'd be stupid
[ __ ] get indicted i'll really be the
first youtuber to
why now today why get on look i was a
star new tour back then the story time
that was popular but now you think about
it why get on the internet today and
tell what the [ __ ] bad [ __ ] you used to
do
that self snitching that is fine it's
now right it doesn't kind of piss yeah
it could be if it's
if it's if it's past the statue of
limitations but not every story a bunch
of crazy is like an illegal like we said
yeah yeah yeah yeah stories that just
some random [ __ ] you have [ __ ] the
first fight i ever gotten in my mind i
did that one i did that one you don't
see like that that's the kind of [ __ ]
people the first house i broke into oh
[ __ ] no i got it
i did that one yeah i did a few of them
and that one's still up yeah
moment before you i did what was that
what were you thinking like i hope
they're not home
nah what it was
now what it was was uh
the homie working my cousin michael they
just hit a house around the corner and i
was asleep
i was mad as [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
and so um
it was probably like 11 that night so
while these [ __ ] in the garage we had
a big ass like flat head like this
and so we have some females that used to
always come to the house
they people was never there so so when
they came to have to smoke with us
i robbed them you know i'm saying
broke in the back window and
yeah that was the first house i hit i
was like
after that we just went stupid like we
hit every house in the neighborhood how
old were you i was like
14. oh okay you're a kid yeah so when
you come out you hit all the houses in
the neighborhood you see the neighbors
yeah
how you doing man i had some crazy
stories but i had
i've been smoking since i was a youngin
bro was the first time you smoke weed
who introduced you to it
it's like a selection of people i used
to steal it from my mama okay this [ __ ]
right here with the black shirt
you know what i'm saying
uh it's just a selection of people but
what happened was um
we left school one time we're in eighth
grade bro
we smoking we went inside the vacant
house
it's me like three of the homies like
two females which is [ __ ] up now that
i think about it was cold but [ __ ] her
home girls left too you know what i'm
saying so
we up in there smoking you in middle
school ain't nobody older than 13 years
old 12 or 13 years old man i was smoking
and we smoking with the female so
like
we trying to hit bro you know what i'm
saying you up in the vacant house out to
school sophia they doing what's up like
back then if you ain't getting no [ __ ]
yeah like eight ninth grade [ __ ]
clowning
for real bro so we trying to hit but
when they get to the females they
smoking one of them hit it
and bro she had a seizure you know what
i'm saying
we all in the house so
everybody gets scared as [ __ ] so we just
run out that [ __ ] her whole
girl's left too so
she on the fourth season by herself
probably like
15 minutes later we're thinking about
going back but we think we're gonna go
to jail we think she dead up in there so
when we leave the house we run around
the corner
we hear the ambulance we like oh [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
we go back up in there they got on the
stretcher
that right there that's when i stopped
smoking with people that
i would never smoke with nobody this is
their first time smoking
i don't do that [ __ ] it's a good rule i
don't do that [ __ ] that [ __ ] scared the
[ __ ] out of me bro i thought i smoked i
thought everybody else smoke you know
what i'm saying
i don't do that [ __ ] like at all
at all bro i was 12 years old
i was stealing away from my mama when i
started smoking my mom used to smoke
heavy you know what i'm saying and she
should leave her [ __ ] up in a little
like pink swishy sweet box i always say
it was a box huh it was a box why do all
people it was a box i don't know what it
is if you were smoking before two
thousand you have a box and yeah yeah
yeah and you're blessing it
he was in i started smoking like i
started smoking with stressfully i'm
starting to doughty like the young
[ __ ] you know i'm saying they're lucky
lucky would she have been mad if she
found out you were taking her weed and
shot yeah she found out eventually
probably like three four years ago i was
telling her because what it was
her and her boyfriend used to argue back
and forth my little brother daddy like
you smoked it long you smoked it
me my cousin my little homeboy kyle we
used to be together all the time bro so
we used to get on the roof and just
smoke that [ __ ] up we didn't get that
you know you know the the writing paper
the part where you write your name
everywhere ain't got the lines in it
because we heard that's where the ink
got mm-hmm so the all-white part was
tear that [ __ ] off roll the weed up now
get on the rope yeah i've got newspaper
joints before out of desperation man i
did that [ __ ] for like a year straight
same all right newspaper yeah with ink
in it
bro
i know what to do and they and it's
stiffer i didn't really know how to roll
too good so it's like yeah
it tastes like [ __ ]
i mean we all did this [ __ ] as a kid i
did it bro we all had to smoke grass
real grassy in there
for real bro
you never died
[Music]
before so he ain't never lucky it's like
actual dirt yeah joe dirk joe dierte
yeah i'm so happy all right i love that
[ __ ] movie
um yo i got hella og if you guys want to
roll more blunts too cause if you don't
like smoking yeah i appreciate it yeah
yeah yeah uh
take off now we're on your timer
uh one of our fans out of buffalo i'm
from buffalo but i don't know this kid
but he sent me i felt like
oh that's hard [ __ ] good looking out
it's hard as [ __ ]
right there yeah yeah
all right
i gotta be honest man i forgot what
we're talking about before we stop
did you forget i forgot you telling the
story about uh the first break being in
[ __ ]
the first break
yeah yeah no no it was fast
man
yeah yeah no we passed that too damn i'm
late too what the [ __ ] are we all right
now stress weed
stress no smoking ghosts
it may look like it was a bleep guys it
was about five minutes i forgot it was
10 minutes man give him some time
all right so
do you smoke cash
yeah
yeah i like that response i just i just
i just don't [ __ ] with the cookie i mean
the edibles and all that oh you don't
[ __ ] edibles yeah no i don't [ __ ]
with hybrid off the tv either bro
belgium
yeah oh geez i got this new skittle
cross just because my
the weeds gone downhill the prices are
crazy right bro it is so cheap right now
how much for that i'll try the weed it's
nothing for a cube
that's why i'm just trying to smoke it
but i got the og i just can't stay away
from all right that's it that's all i
spoke about this because i grew up on
that [ __ ] we still got that [ __ ] uh
doughty back in the day that's what you
called it
you're from out here yeah all right so
you're i'm from up north remember uh by
fresno merced you know where that's at
no no
um
it's like two hours from sacramento too
hard i don't know what i said no i just
know about like fairfield and all that
[ __ ] in between there oh okay okay uh
well bakersfield i'm two and a half
hours from bakersfield that's right i
know okay but it looks like bakersfield
i'm in the
agriculture [ __ ] meth and that's
about it yeah
damn
you say you did what though
i'm saying uh that's where i grew up at
so all we had was uh cookies like with
cookies and all the super fire hey now
hold on not to cut you off now you um
mention bakersfield yeah shout out to
the bakersfield rappers out there
they'll be doing their thing bro i think
that's one of the cities that just
overlooked all the time and it's a lot
of telling out there you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah i lived out there i
lived out there for a minute
and it's a lot of time and
[ __ ] gonna catch on soon you know what
i'm saying
so shout out to all the rappers up in
baggage field yeah good [ __ ] how long
are you how long have you been there
for a couple years like three years
damn dude that's crazy you live in
maine's real big
i mean i love the fact i love california
but bakersfield's just like my town yeah
they do bro it ain't nothing to do with
a lot of drugs and that's about it it's
a lot of joy it's a fire weed out there
so fire it's all fire
thing about my channel i'm telling you
it's between la and the bay yeah yeah
where all the stops are
so it's like when people want to dump
off some packs where they get to la
that's where they do it at
baggage field is underwrited on a lot of
[ __ ] bro it is it is it's i mean it's
underrated
that's the that's the last spot that's
the hub yeah that's dope right there
all right so the reason i was asking the
story times and the reason you stopped
doing the story times
um
if you had to do new ones
right now if you're like yo let's film i
got 40 fools out here to do production
right now
what would you what would you do right
now if you had to pick one story to tell
that wouldn't get your ass in trouble
like what could you tell from your
experience of you being a youtube like
what stories time i do right now if you
had to choose one
because this is a question i know a fan
would be like yo how did you not ask
my son from b12 on friday
my oldest son and when i got autism
and that [ __ ] just starts uh talking
for the first time
like three weeks ago holy [ __ ] yeah i
did that story time because that [ __ ]
was dope the whole day you know what i'm
saying
as soon as i got back from hawaii
i'd do that one that'd be like a 40
minute story time
i'm not getting indicted over that one
you know saying it's it's dope it was
overwhelming
or was it
nah they told me you never talked you're
non-verbal at all not verbal at all it
just happened just happened wow wow
that [ __ ]
so i do that one
no that [ __ ] made me cry [ __ ] for like
two days in a row
yeah i fell into my stomach right now
you know what i'm saying and that [ __ ]
was dope
my baby mama's still crying yeah i'm
saying so
and it's crazy as soon as he talked he
knew our name he knew the dog's name you
know i say sit down i want to eat i
wanna everything it was all just right
there he just couldn't get it out yeah
everything
just one day one day
one day
wow yeah that's like a movie yeah i'll
say that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hey
that [ __ ] yeah and this is recent it's
racing
it's racially inaudible wow he's about
to be 12 years old yeah up on friday
august 6th i mean saturday august 6.
when it has to do with your kid it
weighs it makes you so psychotically
crazy when they're going through
something like my son just went through
surgery big time surgery
it's like i can't and
something like that it's like i just i
commend parents that yeah day in and day
out
and just a lot bro you know what i'm
saying that you got to go through it
they telling you something wrong with
your son you swearing up and down it's
not it's hard to deal with it you know
what i'm saying it
just come with the facts like
i got a disabled son like all i said
heavy
it's more school
special ed classes
meetings you know what i'm saying
it's just a lot of [ __ ] counseling
yeah i'm trying to scream for [ __ ] can't
get it out like that [ __ ] heavy bro
that's another reason why i say youtube
you know what i'm saying because
if i wasn't able to get no money i
wouldn't be able to like to sit at home
and get the money you wouldn't be there
for them exactly yeah exactly i love you
too a lot of the [ __ ] that created
youtube the owner or whoever that is bro
for real that should change my life
forever in a whole different way too
yeah
damn man i'm [ __ ] very happy to hear
that even if it's just that one that one
day like you got it that one day i said
it happened like at 1 30 in the
afternoon
you know
you know he started talking to my son i
got a younger son 8 years old my son dj
and dj came to the house like stefan
just said um go give me something to
drink or something like that yeah
and but they went upstairs i was in the
room kicking it they went upstairs to
like mama
and so then she came and told me i'm
like what came up here she's like say
what's up dad he was like what's up dad
bro i broke down [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah wow
did you were you able to speak to him
though like asked me yeah
just kept smiling every time we asked
him why he went talking he just beat
he smiled he said he don't know
what i'm saying but yeah that's an
amazing sign bro that's amazing that's
amazing and that was the only thing that
kept them out of um
they had a men's special way
because you know with autistic kids they
make like these little gestures and they
hum and
do all this [ __ ] yeah i did uh pals
houses uh for disabled kids i did it for
like six years school yeah so yeah like
every spectrum you can think of there's
there's verbal people there's people
like why is this kid in the class like
oh no no now i understand it's learning
super fast
sometimes there's a learning disability
sometimes it's a verbal thing or a
physical thing where they can't control
their body and stuff but i never heard
of like a spur of spirit of clarity like
that that's amazing
that's great man
yeah that [ __ ] encourage you bro
you say great man yeah so you have two
you have two babies you know
nice thomas been with this girl for
about damn near 20 years and then she
said what he did
ladies i've been with my my fiance for
like almost 11 years you ain't got no
kids
why not y'all know uh i'm not ready man
because i know as soon as i want to like
you like i could be there all day i need
to play my kids though you know what i'm
saying that should just happen oh same
with him
how many you got three three
yeah i got a 14 14 now oh yeah yeah how
old are you 35
oh yeah you've been [ __ ] for a long
time
you got the yeah
[Laughter]
like my daughter's friends and [ __ ] and
their older siblings are all fans of the
podcast now all blowing me up and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] funny
no especially you have you know
for me for the kids man my mom had my
sister at 15 me at 17.
i saw my mom go through the [ __ ] right
you know my dad drug addict my mom was a
drug addict too
yeah
you know i mean i don't know how you
grew up but like going to school like no
i'm good i ate before i got here
but i'm [ __ ] starving yeah i've been
through all that i've been through all
right not asking for shoes school
clothes not tripping not crying on
christmas i mean
what's up you're right
i grew up in the house my whole life i
never had my room uh my own room it was
one of us in the seven-bedroom house you
know what i'm saying
it was one of those grew up in south
central right
all right you mean seven of you in one
bedroom seven nuts yeah seven nothing in
one bedroom yeah
yeah we had a two bedroom i'm always out
of ten my daddy got three
and it was it it was just
they didn't stay with us though i was
the like the seven was my mama
and it was just one room bro
yeah so that's why because i wasn't
ready i i wouldn't start making money
until recently i wasn't ready like i
don't want my kid to go yo don't worry
we can't make this volcano [ __ ]
yeah cause that was me but like yo we
gotta make a volcano but i don't wanna
ask my mom put her through that [ __ ] cuz
i know she don't got that [ __ ] that's
why i don't have kids right because i
just don't want that i want to be like
i want to be those older people like you
waited till you're 40. what the [ __ ]
you're just really approaching the age
that you should be to like be having
kids you're doing you know what i'm
saying i'm trying you good you're good
yeah i'm straight you guys
yeah
i'm straight all right uh what what time
is it i know i know you had a flight
yeah we got like two minutes
like two minutes so can i let me real
quick if we're talking top fives
currently on the watch is that it's a
datejust
oh that's it or yeah all right 41 oyster
perpetual stainless steel exactly what
it is yeah yeah yeah
i told you that bro yeah so he gifted it
to me on the show about what 15 20
episodes oh yeah that's how you take
care of your boys huh he's supposed to
do jewelry but i know he would rock it
yeah yeah he's supposed to bro that's
what's up that's what's up yeah this is
a team right here man that's what's up
top five all time rappers yeah
nepsi young thug
lloyd banks
oh rick ross in the game
that's my top five rick ross in the top
five yeah nipsey lloyd banks young thug
rick ross and gang
i ain't never there that's we
we usually ask this when we talk about
people that are in the music heavy it'll
always be my top five people usually
take a lot of things
yeah you know that's all that's always
been my top five now if you were to put
out like a
i don't know what the version modern day
version the double xl freshman the
double xl not even a double xl what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna put that i'm gonna
put out one of the dopest compilation
albums that's a dj drama [ __ ]
with all these [ __ ] favorite rappers
that they like today from the nlp
choppers the
polo jesus and all that yeah we finna do
that
good [ __ ] thank you we're gonna do that
i'm gonna pick all the beats i'm gonna
pick all the rappers can't do like
[Music]
yeah
like your noriega one yeah sorry in the
works i'm sorry you know works let's go
yeah that's some good [ __ ] it's just
something for people to [ __ ] do man
what about dj goes music spotify apple
music that's already on there you can go
there right now it's on there i'm gonna
drop a record on my birthday what's your
birthday
september 24th september 6 oh yeah
that's my little brother's birthday yeah
yeah yeah that's mine august 25th i'm
dropping my first august 25th project in
about eight years recorded at that next
studio yeah yeah but [ __ ] drops this
smacking
next month august next month yeah yeah
it's funny you say that that's hard it's
about to be sick that's all i only heard
like two but the one i heard about
that's hard
for real
that's all uh i know you got a fight
where can everybody support you at where
can everybody find because you gotta lie
everything dj goes bro dj goes just
everything dj goes yeah uh uh what's
that tick tock one thing about tick tock
you get paid on tick tock
i heard about that bro one thing i don't
have a tick tock but i got over a
billion views over there right people
using your [ __ ] i do not have a tick
tock everybody keep asking me that's not
my tick tock i ain't got one but
everything dj goes i ain't got no
twitter either you can't add me you know
what i'm saying so
instagram youtube
that's it facebook you know what i'm
saying twitch discord twitch discord
there you go you
bro appreciate you appreciating you're
popping up on this patreon
yeah remember you can't get no [ __ ]
merch until about september yeah like
like yeah in the end august beginning of
september you know what i'm saying i got
you [ __ ]
and if y'all seen it
if you order something now that's you're
gonna get it till the end i'm telling
you now bro because i promise you after
this i'm gonna get like 100 and they
gonna just sit there i'm telling you i'm
not sending that [ __ ] so
you know get your refund or whatever
i go through paypal so they'll be
cheering you get your refund back but
i'm not sending nothing just until after
like august 20th or something so dope to
hear that you do all your own [ __ ] yeah
that's in-house that's your that's you
and all this i'm doing i gotta i just
left cool kicks bro
so you gotta die let somebody go there
last night the whole little
oh the shoe shopping yeah that's what
you were doing
i thought you meant when you text me
like oh he's just buying some shoes no i
did the whole little episode
on camera in case it comes out i was
like what you get
out there in the suv yo saying she was
in the suv good [ __ ]
yeah all right man i appreciate you
thank you for being here man yeah all
the time all the time i'm coming back
i'm gonna come back yeah first interview
ever first interview ever
podcast thank you we appreciate it thank
you guys for being here thank you yeah i
appreciate y'all dope your little squad
ghost gang and all that man i love y'all
marty thank you for coming man we know
this was the first one we appreciate it
and we appreciate it and next time
community we have next time you're gonna
have some franco leafs no i don't follow
it back
to frontiers
the big turkey
all right i got a homie that [ __ ] with
that heavy so i got you everybody was a
broad brother leaf
no no i'll find those for you too
everybody just says it's the best i know
you're gonna hook me up next time your
whole setup is dope bro it's a dopest
thing i've seen appreciate it when it
comes to podcasts
thank you
thank you thank you ever we did it we
did it with our homies so appreciate
that all right
thank you all right guys this has been
the dj ghost podcast for marty and i
have a dope ass day 100. yeah let's go
[ __ ]
damn i got a fat joint too to smoke
right now my height
perfect